a judge ruled coffeeshops must serve
coffee with a cancer warning in
California
the judge said yesterday that chains
like Starbucks and Whole Foods must post
signs telling people about a possible
cancer-causing chemical in their coffee
the chemical called acrylamide is
produced in the roasting process and a
Warner is here with what this means for
coffee lovers and you're trying to ruin
my morning coffee the lawsuit was filed
under California's Prop 65 it requires
businesses to notify consumers of
exposure to cancer-causing chemicals now
while the coffee industry has long
claimed the level of acrylamide in
coffee is harmless the judge ruled it
failed to prove there's no significant
risk the coffee cancer battle has been
brewing in California for years and on
Thursday Starbucks and other retailers
were roasted some ninety retailers named
in the suit will now be required to post
warnings that a chemical found in coffee
may cause cancer
acrylamide is formed naturally when
coffee is brewed in studies high doses
of acrylamide has caused cancer in mice
it's kind of difficult to to know where
the line should be drawn California law
professor Marsha Cohen says time will
tell how this ruling will impact coffee
retailers the real question is whether a
year from now fewer people will have
started their morning at a coffee shop
in California the nonprofit group that
filed the lawsuit said it's grateful for
the ruling adding it's hopeful that the
coffee industry will now agree to reduce
acrylamide levels I'll have maybe just
to express us every other day instead of
46 cancer warning signs like this one
are already posted across California and
bars even at Disneyland
but some believe warnings about coffee
mean prop 65 has gone too far
I believe in transparency CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus says
coffee in moderation has been shown to
potentially decrease the risk of certain
cancers so you put a bold declaration X
cause cancer when there isn't data to
that effect in humans to me it causes
panic
rather than informed knowledge well the
National Coffee Association says the
lawsuit makes a mockery of prop 65
confuses consumers and doesn't improve
public health defendants can appeal the
judge's decision civil penalties for
coffee retailers still need to be set
and the penalties could be in the
millions maybe we'll see some coffee
companies settled out some sellers of
coffee but rarely do we get to do a
story where the prop is something we
drink we actually drink I'm still
drinking Michael thank you Anna yeah
thanks thank you